the theme of going beyond things that's
right yes so when I saw the title of the
workshop I kind of wondered what I can
contribute it and I was kind of stunned
because a whole percent of what I do is
like differential privacy right we're
barely trying to kind of achieve the
pressure privacy or trying very hard so
like going beyond your actual privacy is
like beyond my wildest dreams so I
decided to kind of take you beyond in
some in a different direction and
basically this is like the picture that
we all all know and love and it's kind
of there are some salient salient
features of this picture that we sort of
like we've gotten used to but the fact
is they still rub certain people a wrong
way and here I want to put up the the a
quote from the paper by one of the
prominent
cryptographers feel rug away from his
essay titled the moral character of
cryptographic book from a few years ago
and in that paper it's a kind of long
essay on kind of musings on this this or
state of modern cryptography but one
quote is particularly relevant as it
relates to different privacy it says
that the model of your privacy
implicitly pasted the database owner the
curator as the good guy and the user
screwing it the adversary if power
meaning the man would just agree to
fight with the answers in the right way
it could be fine for it to hold massive
massive personal data about each of us
but the history of data privacy breaches
suggests that the principal threat to us
is from the database owner honor itself
and those that Dean wholesale access to
the data
and kind of I I saw in like or he reach
out to me with an early draft of that
essay I kind of address some of his
points he summarized my point of view
fairly it's in the paper and kind of it
concludes with saying that the
definition of differential privacy is
agnostic to the data model which I tend
to believe in but then he gets the last
word which is no actual mechanism can be
agnostic to what data resides where and
at the point when a data mining
architecture mechanism is laid down
considerations of efficiency familiarity
and economic make it easy to predict
what will happen almost always a
centralized design will emerge which
leads him to the very damning conclusion
that to me differential privacy may may
be as authoritarian in its conceptual
underpinnings as identity based
encryption so basically it's like
Minecraft I being a differential privacy
kind of
so one of the examples that I given him
that kind of goes against this his
thesis is that local differential
privacy explicitly gives power to to the
to the end-users yes like it's it's
perfectly compatible with the definition
with the canonical definition of
differential privacy and it achieves the
variance that he kind of argues for the
problem with local differential privacy
and like I put up this like I use this
light in the at the bootcamp in the very
beginning of the semester that it's kind
of it's a privilege of of the rich it's
like it's no small accident that the
companies that publicly deploy at local
different privacy are companies with
like more than a billion users is this
sarcoma Club and again that kind of
would if I can continue my imagine a
conversation with the road away he'll
say ha I got you they're like it's only
the companies with the trillion dollar
relations can afford to do it locally
pressure by this year and like the
public the okay so you would say
something nasty about capitalism okay
the second argument that I I kind of put
forward which is that there is an
alternative to implementing curator as
this mechanism that works data and kind
of and model on immediate access to data
the alternative is to simulate a greater
be a multi-party competition and for
those of you who are no cryptographers
that's the technology that emerged in
the early 80s that allows a coalition of
people mutually distrustful individuals
and like the distrust goes both to argue
security
it's we have to design our mechanism has
to be resistant to some participants who
worked undermine the book working on
this mechanism but it also kind of
allows some measure of privacy if not
all participants collaborate then
typically we can have a very good
protection for data that we contribute
to the mechanism and not incidentally
one of the very early papers on
differential privacy with that appeared
in 2006 explored this very moment this
very model so specifically that in that
paper and we consider the question of
the sort of the canonical problem in in
disable competitions of computing the
sum of individual bits and computing the
sum in an NPC way is very simple the
hard part turns out to be not very not
impossible but like the more interesting
mathematical interesting part and that
be generating noise in an efficient
manner and it's not surprising that
generating at the Gaussian noise the
Gaussian noise is a better match for
this distributed generation and that
paper is best known for introducing the
notion of epsilon Delta differential
privacy and for introducing Gaussian
noise in the differential private
context to with her the differential
privacy
sorry Gaussian noise as a way of
protecting privacy ax was like goes back
to to the vertical partition databases
by Clemente and Cynthia but right
that's right yeah even even though yes
but so can have that concept of replaces
the curator with a coalition of people
working to exist implementing
multi-party computation was was very
much in our our minds at the very
beginning of differential privacy first
of all but 13 years and I've taken the
snapshot from a Google i/o which is the
main Google developer conference from
the keynote address by Google CEO sundar
Pichai where he presented yesterday with
exactly 24 hours ago he talked about the
work on federated learning that power
the currently power Seaborg at least for
American English where your devices
engage in the same in the exactly the
kind of multi-party computation that
kind of we sketched out many years ago
to be precise currently these devices
don't generate noise distribution so the
what they do is that they kind of the
aggregator updates to the keyboard model
gioberti's like what I think
specifically it's a it's this one line
where it proposes kind of suggested good
in what sense it's exactly the same a
grenade
like think of it's not in the same way
but multiple completion is a very it's
an umbrella definition it can I can
tolerate many a possible can you like
say precisely what it is it's honest but
curious aggregation it's so I should
have known an answer but kind of there's
a paper from 2017 that although the
mercury is resistant to the kind of Nov
3 coalition purchase I'm I cannot say
whether it's exactly the same model
which is implemented in the current
iteration of viewport I just don't know
this I don't know what is currently
running on your cellphone's on your
Android phones but there's a
well-documented protocol that is a close
approximation to what what is being run
so and this is from the point of view of
multi-party competitions that's a really
baby step of computing they distributed
some what about doing more complex
computations and a canonical problem in
in in most parts compilations it's
called traveling it's called permit a
permutation and and again we kind of so
potential for using this multi-particle
of this capability to enhance our
deprived ignorant differentially privacy
guarantees
we first described it in the pocket
paper that appeared at the system's
conference 27 2017 and basically at the
heart of that of the proposal was the
idea that we'll do some local
differential privacy on the devices then
we'll pass this inputs through a
sequence of chapters and the output is
going to be a fully anonymous version of
what what came in so and again that
model is being implemented in in this
new operation system is that Google is
working on it's called fuchsia and
there's a the system is fully open
sourced and you can check out the
progress on implementation of this
particular technology called cobble
under future and it it's based on the
kind of the this paradigm outlined two
years ago this travel model was led to
fairly interesting and insightful work
in theory that demonstrated that it is
fundamentally fundamentally sound
approach to amplifying local
differential privacy of making of
translating local differential privacy
guarantees to a stronger central
differential privacy
but again cryptographers intelligence
would recognize the shuffle model and
something that appeared in the
cryptographic literature back in 1981
and that was a canonical problem for for
kind of anonymous communications or a
clinical building block for anonymous
communications were exactly this
architecture was described by by david
chung and in this light has appeared in
hundreds or thousands of talks and
usually as a motivation and usually it
was introduced as a way of conducting
elections and the way this slide was
motivated is by saying that let's
imagine that this boxes are going to be
run by this mutually distrustful
purchase EF f s heal you of the the
Republican Party the Democrat Party and
as a card-carrying cryptographer we just
actually Troy I'm a member of I share
I'm kind of substance so I have to take
it as an article of faith that that
slide makes sense because like again
it's been used in thousands of papers
but let's face it even though this idea
was reticulated back in nineteen eighty
eight and one it's now been done why is
that well because like EF happened
she'll you they don't run services it's
not their thing the Democratic Party and
GOP the dual but they wish they hadn't
and even though like they are mutually
stressful we know that both of these
parties can be compromised by a single
agent who kind of coordinate there are
secrets and kind of will mess up with
their internal operations
so really I'm sad to say but that
particular slide
science fiction and all implementations
of multi-part computations didn't follow
this product the purchase which were
running the servers were basically paid
for and operated by someone who had a
stake in the final outcome so if we
acknowledge this truth how kind of what
other reasonable ways of of making of
bringing this call that reality so again
I want to emphasize that will like the
idea of regular shutters we have
theoretical evidence that the amplify
privacy the the not only the evidence is
there but also kind of the intuition is
there if the inputs are fully stripped
of of identified information and like
put in a large back then the output is
going to be more private than before and
again I don't have to appeal to theorems
this is how elections have been
conducted for centuries for but it's
called the Australian ballot like the
secret ballot using this hardware device
is called Earth's
and to kind of get us closer to
implementation of suspicion I want to
drink up what's called as HDX software
got extensions that were introduced by
Intel if years ago and kind of are
commercially available start in 2015 and
basically the enable creation of secure
enclaves and the secure Enclave I won't
get into kind of the technical
definition what it is but basically it's
a code that can be executed in a
completely attack manner by the host
operating system so the operation system
controls the inputs control observes the
output it doesn't control what's going
on inside this black box and this black
box can do encryption decryption using
keys that are not accessible by the
hostile person system it supposed to
motorization support sealing I'll say a
few words what remote at the station is
that's kind of a relatively complex
picture and the actual protocol is a bit
more complex than this diagram makes a
belief but in principle what it says is
that the Challenger which is a purchase
that is trying to kind of that's relies
on enclaves for execution of its code it
will verify that the code writing in the
data center is what it what I think it
is what it claims to be like it can
authenticate the code exactly
and there's it can enable keys that are
only accessible within this black box
and so it will kind of it can it can
negotiate keys either at the private
keys or or public key public to private
public private key pairs that are only
accessible to within this black box and
the beauty of it is that the whole
suppressing system the data center pays
for everything
so it sort of results this question of
why would I steal your or AFF
participate in the scheme because they
don't have technical abilities they
don't have resources and it's not part
of their Charter to enable these
competitions the answer is that as long
as you'd trust that ng axis are
guaranteeing that the data center the
hotel person system can pick inside them
you can rely on on on the on the data
center for logistics and for the HDX for
security and it suggests that kind of to
all of us that a very kind of neutral
and economical way of running
differential private computations is by
purchase sending their data shield to an
AJAX that is going to run it
contemplated frankly private
computations and and from the outside it
will is going to look roughly like the
original client-server architecture but
without the curator having this
unfettered access to the raw data so
it's the problem yeah
these enclaves on the one hand you can
they can publish t-test they can you
know this is my Enclave I don't want to
give you access to it so I'm sort of
getting the model exactly so you can yes
so basically the share insurance
application decides what code it trusts
inside the Ajax the code can do
something that only the application can
see the code the code can do something
that leaks information or like polish
some information to the outside the code
can the enclaves can collaborate can
kind of share data between themselves so
it's basically your ally inside the data
center
you're like think of it this like I can
I'm bad with analogies but look as an
embassy it's like the operating system
cannot enter it legally the embassy will
execute your orders
you decide what code you're going to run
the code is exact an examiner you can
authenticate it it's going to be if you
are not comfortable writing this code
you just walk away so o AG axis we are
designed to support capitation that we'd
like them to do so you have to kind of
jump through some hoops for example they
have limited memory one of the kind of
this communica problem of shuffling off
taking data and just like encrypting it
in air and water you have to do it like
given this like we want to operate on
gigabytes of data given this like
relatively small window like a secure
memory in size Ajax but it's a technical
problem that you can solve more kind of
concerning is the fact that age X's are
not the current generation as Y axis
kind of has a number of of leakage
problems and people who are kind of
invested into this fully a software view
of of security the point out correctly
that AG axis are not kind of don't
provide this kind of fully isolated
environment as they promised to do
whether it's a temporary state of
affairs were will it will stay with us
for perpetuity I have no clue but that's
kind of a concern that like it weighs on
the users of Ajax for this purpose is
that current generation of AG axis is
not as robust as we'd like them to be
having said that when I'm talking about
the y-axis there's an entire family of
similarly of enclaves with overlapping
capabilities deployed by other players
in the hardware space Apple has its own
secure elements on phones
as we made very prominent by the Sun
partnered in our case mg has on has
their own version of HD access etc like
risk 5 so we are looking at the entire
kind of space of hardware isolation
which and my thesis is that it's is
going to be super we have to be aware of
it because it actually solves one of the
big problems that we have
so and another problem that AG axis had
was that the inertial privacy so there
look their initial implementation was
vulnerable to remind the tax where you
could just reset hedge the accent and
three rounded from the kind of from the
from the same space from the same state
and differential private she doesn't
like that because like you can just
exhaust your privacy budget in no time
no time and there are some solution to
it called monotone encounters that who
have made part of the Ajax model shortly
after its release there are alternative
solutions like using collisions of
enclaves to kind of make sure that none
of them gets remind and finally we can
like think of creative ways of using
block chains okay so I have just a few
minutes left and I want to mention
another way of of going beyond software
and if this idea is we are kind of of
using energy axis we are kind of are
fairly mature like we experiment
experiment with them it's something that
is not kind of available and in the data
center as far as I can tell but if
there's demand we'll get there in a few
in a few years time what I'm going to
talk about is like not even calculate
it's like 1% baked or like negatively
baked you have to dig out of the hole to
get somewhere so again this is the
picture that we're all familiar with and
kind of a picture that I want you to
consider is the one where the database
instead of this neatly arranged set of
records is some set of entangled quantum
bits qubits and each each query
corresponds to a measurement of the
quantum state so the all competitions of
our quantum states are the Canada store
information except for measurements that
do
the measurements the explicitly kind of
add noise if the quantum state state is
set up in the right way and kind of with
each measurements you can collapse in
this quantum state and lo and behold you
in doubt like something that like
superficial looks like a like a like
exponential based mechanism and this
particular question of whether a quantum
state this quantum mechanics is
compatible with different her privacy
it's been asked many times before and
this is why I'm saying is that look we
have to get out of the negative space
because like I think the answer so far
that no one knows how to kind of make it
happen how to make it work I want to
kind of call out this paper by Scott
Aaronson guy roblem who is like making
rounds in the blogosphere and basically
it falls into this category of like well
I kind of want to rephrase it as don't
ask what differential privacy can do for
you ask what you can do for differential
privacy so the that paper the used tools
from differential privacy to solve
problems in quantum computing and kind
of I challenge you to think of ways of
using quantum computing to solve
problems in general differential privacy
so to conclude I think by accepting
hardware as a root rot not the root of
trust but in addition to hardware we
have to use some other anchors to to
kind of to bootstrap hardware not to use
it as the only check on look the only
defense by accepting hardware is the
root of trust we can expand our design
space of algorithms that can be
implemented in practice and be actually
useful and I also want to expand the
definition of hardware like to also
think about some more exotic
architectures like so I guess one
question that comes up with any of these
architectures I mentioned is like the
hard hardware is not the only thing you
have to trust here you still have to
like look at the code and inspect it and
check that you're doing it does what you
claim it what you think it's doing and
it feels like that's a big part of the
problem with that sort of distributed
software architecture also right like
one can imagine models for like funding
this distributed architecture evident
like it's not clear to me what the main
obstacle to the existence of these types
of like collaborative platforms for
analyzing data is it really like the
cost of running the platform which is
what you talked about or is it like the
fact that we all you know in the end all
that software is probably going to be
written by one person or one team and
current state of affairs basically have
to trust them to be to operate in good
faith and I think all of it and what you
mentioned in addition there's kind of
companies are kind of reluctant to turn
to allow someone else has kind of as
they as a failure point as a so just
kind of if you're collecting sensitive
data then introduce someone else into
the loop sounds looks kind of wrong okay
but then that that raises the point that
like just as no not everyone can afford
the data that's required for local
differential privacy not everyone can
form the infrastructure that's required
to like a symbol a platform like the one
you
just kind of yeah I want to point
despite decades of research and and a
lot of serious efforts in launching
commercials offerings in the most
practical in the NPC space we have we
haven't seen it happening compared to AG
axis that seem to be together I guess
you could argue that allowing these rich
groups to move from local differential
privacy to centralized in a way that
still trusted could be a win even if
we're not yet helping a lot of what we
do is about helping